We will now go through
a derivation of the
law of total variance.
This particular derivation
is not insightful.
It will not really give you any
intuition as to why the
law of total variance
is correct.
On the other hand, it involves
some interesting manipulations
that will be useful to be able
to follow, and understand the
kinds of objects that they're
being moved around, and why
each step is valid.
Our derivation relies on the
standard formula that we have
on how to calculate variances.
And our first step is to apply
this formula to the
conditional variance.
Now, the conditional variance is
like an ordinary variance,
except that it is calculated
in a conditional universe.
So we apply this formula, except
that the expectation of
X squared is the expectation
calculated in
the conditional universe.
And similarly, for the next term
it is the square of the
expected value of X. But it's
the expected value of X as
calculated in the conditional
universe.
So this is an equality
between numbers.
What does it translate to?
This has been defined as a
random variable that takes
this value when capital Y
is equal to little y.
What is the random variable
that takes this value when
capital Y is little y?
Well, this random variable here
is a random variable that
takes this value when capital
Y is equal to little y.
And this random variable here
is a random variable that
takes this numerical value
when capital Y is
equal to little y.
So to summarize, this is the
random variable that takes
this numerical value
when capital Y is
equal to little y.
And this is a random variable
that takes this value when
capital Y is equal
to little y.
This expression, the left hand
side is equal to the right
hand side for all y's.
And therefore, this random
variable and that random
variable always take the same
numerical values no matter
what y happens to be.
So these are identical
random variables.
And so we have this equality
between random variables.
The next step as we're working
towards calculating this first
term here in the law of total
variance is to take the
expectation of this
expression.
What is it?
We take the expectation
of the first term.
It's the expectation of a
conditional expectation.
And according to the law of
iterated expectations, it is
the same as the unconditional
expectation.
And then we have the expected
value of the next term.
Next, we want to make some
progress towards calculating
this second quantity in the
law of total variance.
And the way to calculate it is
to just apply this general
property of variances to the
special case where X gets
replaced by the expected
value of X given Y.
So the first term will be the
expected value of our random
variable squared.
Our random variable is the
expected value of X given Y.
And the second term involves
the expected value of the
random variable whose variance
we're considering.
So it's the expected value
of this random variable.
So it's the expected value of
the conditional expectation.
And everything gets squared.
What is this term?
By the law of iterated
expectations, the expected
value of a conditional
expectation is the same as the
unconditional expectation.
So this last term here
is of this form.
What we will do next is to take
this expression here and
that expression here, and
add them together.
When we add them, we notice that
this term and that term
are the same.
So they cancel out.
And we're left with the expected
value of X squared
minus the square of the
expected value.
But we know that this is the
same as the variance of X. So
we have proved that the sum of
these two terms, which are the
two terms up here, give
us the variance of X.